this is wild Chronicles
humans may fear sharks but it seems
sharks have more to fear from humans
a recent study suggests that overfishing
has slashed the population of sharks
just in the past decade for many species
the numbers have dropped by more than 50
percent despite concerns people continue
reeling in these top predators for food
and sport in South Portland Maine the
shark hunting tournament draws quite a
crowd but these sport fishermen are not
just here for a trophy catch
they're fishing to promote research
mainly degree
they receive a copy of the rules and a
camera to record the Sharks they catch
tag for research and then release the
so-called catch and release tournaments
are popular along the Atlantic seaboard
they'll tag it release and you can track
the fish from miles away Spain de Puerto
Rico along the east coast it's really
the only way you can study a fish now in
the wild
even in summer mornings and Maine can be
cool and Misty
the team's head off in search of sharks
that enter these waters on their summer
migration
on board the karenann the fishermen are
joined by researchers who will study the
catch of the day
snaring a shark takes skill and strength
sharks caught here can weigh many
hundreds of pounds but this one is
smaller
some species of shark grow only a few
inches annually and take 20 years to
become sexually mature their gestation
period lasts along nine months to two
years slow to grow and reproduce sharks
can easily be wiped out by overfishing
after gathering data
the catch is released not everyone
condones this merging of science and
sport fishing but biologists say it
provides them a rare opportunity to
study these vulnerable predators the
biggest benefit for us is literally to
get more data we see more fish and we
talk with more anglers and we'll get to
see more animals over the course of the
summer
national Geographics Tyler Abernathy is
also on board the project his goal is to
attach a critter cam to some of the
larger sharks
this fish is hefty and potentially
dangerous the fishermen and researchers
must move quickly but carefully to
secure the fish and gather data Cuyler
snaps the camera on the dorsal fin it
will record what the shark sees before
releasing and floating to the surface
giving researchers unique insight into
life underwater finally it's time to
release the shark back into the deep
oh he's down
but not all sharks in the tournament
returned to the scene larger mature
sharks are brought in to be weighed
it's 4 o 2.5 these big guys will be
delivered to biologists Leeson a TENS
who studies that remains
we could definitely do our research
without the tournaments the tournaments
make it a lot easier the future brought
in and they let us come sample which is
great we could get them in other ways if
we had to but this just makes it easier
for us by studying the contents of their
stomachs their guts and reproductive
systems
scientists hope to learn more about the
impact of pollution and habitat change
on shark populations
the fishermen say that for the most part
they're here for fun they enjoy the
challenge of catching an apex predator
but many seem pleased that they are in
some ways hoping the researchers
dedicated to protecting sharks I think
this is a very good tournament I agree
with the the practices going on at this
tournament they are trying to limit the
amount of smaller sharks brought in
there's a lot of guys you're getting
points for tagging and releasing small
sharks which again is going to help with
the research in many ways the
cooperation between sportsmen and
conservationists seems natural both have
an interest in keeping a viable
population of sharks in these coastal
waters fishermen scientists say will
hold tournaments and reel in sharks with
or without them by joining forces
researchers get valuable specimens to
study and many sharks give a chance to
live another day this time the fish that
got away is not a loss but a cause for
celebration
check for wild products on your local
PBS station
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium